of coming home for those abandoned by
their parties those who were hounded out
like Luciana bersia
though sadly the results have seen as
lose Luciana
from Parliament and many other talented
MPs such as Tom brake Sam Jima Shakur
Emunah Jane Dodds I'm so sorry I
couldn't get them elected along with so
many more of our wonderful candidates
racism is infecting our politics
terrifyingly it has now become
mainstream a Labour Party mired in
anti-semitism complaints unresolved the
Jewish community fearful it took labour
months to expel a member who wrote about
gassing Jews months when Alastair
Campbell voted Lib Dem they kicked him
out in two days breaks at party
representatives filmed talking about
being outbred by Muslims and reveling in
a story about plans to encase a pig's
head in concrete in the foundations of a
mosque watching that footage I felt sick
yet this is the party that has handed
Boris Johnson the keys to number 10 the
Conservatives are failing on
Islamophobia and the Prime Minister
willingly received the endorsement of
Tommy Robinson Britain's biggest racist
so many people will look at the last few
weeks at these results and be filled
with dread about the future of our
country I understand I'm worried too
this goes beyond our future relationship
with the European Union
it's about our relationships with one
another in the United Kingdom do we
value every individual for who they are
are we an open welcoming inclusive
society
I still believe we are at heart or at
least that we can be but there are many
forces that seek to divide us to a low
resentment and fear to fester and if we
want to be that open-minded warm-hearted
society we need to stand up join
together and fight for it
I'm proud in selection to have fought
for what we and millions of people
believe is the best future for our
country remaining in the European Union
when 19 Labour MPs helped pass Boris
Johnson's brexit deal in the House of
Commons he was clear we had to act we
forced Johnson to request an extension
to article 50 but without labor support
couldn't assemble a majority for a
people's vote leaving a general election
as the only chance to remain in the EU
so I did not shirk the debates and the
phonons I turned up to the interviews
and I stood up proudly for our beliefs
I'm proud that Liberal Democrats have
been the unapologetic voice of remain in
this election giving people the chance
to choose to stop breaks it obviously it
hasn't worked and I like you I'm
devastated about that but I don't regret
trying trying everything because the
prize was to save our future our
children's future in Europe where we can
work together to tackle the climate
emergency trade freely to boost our
living standards and be a strong beacon
for human rights around the world we
have been true to ourselves and true to
our liberal values and as your leader I
have been true to myself to as a Scot as
a Brit as a European as a liberal a
humanist a feminist as a daughter sister
wife and a mom to two small kids being
myself whether people attacked
my vision our my voice my ideas or my
earrings one of the realities of
smashing glass ceilings is that a lot of
broken glass comes down on your head
so I'm proud to have been the first
woman to lead the Liberal Democrats I'm
even more proud that I will not be the
last in Sarah Vera Christine and Leila
we have four fantastic and experienced
women MPs and in Daisy
Munira and Wendy we have exciting new
talent they will take the Commons by
storm I've traveled the country during
this campaign I've loved meeting so many
Lib Dem members and activists the team's
really have been extraordinary with our
party our highest membership numbers in
our history you have shown with optimism
courage and determination thank you all
for everything you've done and I'd like
to say a special thank you to my staff
both in my leaders office and in my
constituency you are all amazing
together we have refused to simply be
spectators sitting on the sidelines
while our country heads down a damaging
path of which breaks it is only the
first step our country is in the grip of
populism with nationalism resurgent in
all its forms it is easy to despair but
I say let's foster hope instead in
Rebekah's so let's hope in the dark she
quotes vaclav havel the kind of Hope I
often think about I understand above all
as a state of mind not a state of the
world hope in this deep and powerful
sense is not the same as joy when things
go well or willingness to invest in
enterprises that are obviously headed
for early success but rather an ability
to work for something because it is good
not just because it stands a chance to
succeed she then goes on to say
hope is not a door but a sense that
there might be a door at some point some
way out of the problems of the present
moment even before that way is found or
followed there will be a door there will
be a way out of this nationalists search
and we have to work together to find it
it is a huge job to be done the answer
is that we step up we organize we join
together though I won't be your leader I
will be walking alongside you
we will reflect regroup and refresh we
must continue to grow our liberal
movement both attracting Lib Dem members
and by reaching out to work with those
who share our values wherever they are
all of us who share an alternative
vision for society have a responsibility
to learn from this result and find new
answers next week is the shortest day we
will see more light in the future join
us for that journey let's explore the
way together with hope in our hearts
[Applause]